Alice: 你能不能装着我这个手机
Alice: Can you carry my phone?
Alice: 我没兜 谢谢
Alice: I don't have pockets, thanks.
Alice: 我靠 你再给我弄丢了 装你兜里
Alice: Oh no, if you lose it again, put it in your pocket.
Alice: 能不能对我多一点耐心
Alice: Can you be more patient with me?
刘婷:好给我吧
Liu Ting: Okay, give it to me.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
刘婷:满意了
Liu Ting: Happy now?
Alice: 满意了
Alice: Yes, happy now.
Alice: 哈哈哈 好可爱
Alice: Hahaha, so cute.
Lucia:卡皮巴拉
Lucia: Capybara.
Alice:皮巴
Alice: Piba.
Alice: 你要欣赏一下吗
Alice: Do you want to appreciate it?
Nicous: 对啊
Nicous: Yeah.
Lucia:这个你可以直接发给靖康
Lucia: You can send this directly to Jingkang.
Jake: 可以可以谢谢
Jake: Sure, sure, thanks.
Jake: 我我可以打开一个这个
Jake: Can I open this?
Lucia:哦这个
Lucia: Oh, this.
Jack: 所以这个玩法是干什么的
Jack: So what's the point of this game?
Lucia: 这是他最常摆的pose
Lucia: This is his most common pose.
Jake:对这是叫着呢
Jake: Yeah, he's calling out.
刘婷:我以为这是手动打码呢
Liu Ting: I thought this was manual censorship.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Nicous: 是啊
Nicous: Yeah.
Nicous: 然后好多只袜子
Nicous: And lots of socks.
Jack: 哈哈哈
Jack: Hahaha.
Alice: 出去玩吧啊
Alice: Let's go out and play, okay?
刘婷:啊
Liu Ting: Ah.
Alice: 出去加入
Alice: Let's go join.
Alice: 上钟
Alice: On the clock.
女嘉宾:我要几点走啊
Female Guest: When should I leave?
女嘉宾:走晚了赶不上车了
Female Guest: If I leave late, I won't catch the bus.
Alice: 几点了
Alice: What time is it?
女嘉宾:7点多了
Female Guest: It's past 7.
Alice: 没事你想走你就 就是你
Alice: It's okay, leave whenever you want.
Alice:看你的时间安排 嗯
Alice: Just manage your time, hmm.
女嘉宾:嗯看时间
Female Guest: Hmm, depends on the time.
嘉宾:嗯
Guest: Hmm.
男嘉宾:去哪啊你们
Male Guest: Where are you going?
男嘉宾:回去回朝阳
Male Guest: Going back to Chaoyang.
Alice: 你你要回海淀吧
Alice: You, you are going back to Haidian, right?
Alice: 打车不知道报销不报销
Alice: I don't know if taking a taxi will be reimbursed.
男嘉宾:报销我就打
Male Guest: If it's reimbursed, I'll take it.
刘婷:有这种好事哈哈
Liu Ting: Is there such a good deal? Haha
男嘉宾:坐车回去两个小时
Male Guest: It takes two hours to get back by car.
Alice: 是
Alice: Yes.
女嘉宾:打车回去哈
Female Guest: Take a taxi back, huh?
Alice: 哈
Alice: Ha.
女嘉宾:这氛围还挺适合拍照的
Female Guest: The atmosphere here is quite nice for taking pictures.
女嘉宾:就是可能有点
Female Guest: But it might be a bit...
女嘉宾:就是这里没有光嘛只有那个
Female Guest: There's no light here, only that...
男嘉宾:只有闪光灯
Male Guest: Only the flash.
Alice: 你拿这个打过鸟吗
Alice: Have you ever used this to shoot birds?
Alice: 长焦吗用
Alice: Do you use a telephoto lens?
Alice: 真好
Alice: That's nice.
Alice: 刘婷我们拍个情侣照吧
Alice: Liu Ting, let's take a couple photo.
Alice: 虽然不是情侣好吗
Alice: Even though we're not a couple, okay?
女嘉宾:原来环球在通州区
Female Guest: So Universal is in Tongzhou District.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
女嘉宾:嗯就从
Female Guest: From...
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Shure:  我们的500万还没开奖呢
Shure: Our 5 million prize hasn't been drawn yet.
Alice:就这附近呢
Alice: It's just around here.
女嘉宾:对
Female Guest: Yeah.
女嘉宾:坐地铁来说
Female Guest: By subway...
女嘉宾:有一站是通州北岳
Female Guest: There's a station called Tongzhou Beiyue.
Alice: 就你教教我
Alice: Just teach me.
刘婷:太太难了
Liu Ting: It's too difficult.
刘婷:对你来说
Liu Ting: For you.
刘婷:OK
Liu Ting: OK.
Alice: 没错我们就是排
Alice: Yeah, when we were practicing...
Alice: 我就是排舞的时候跳的最哎
Alice: I was the worst at dancing.
刘婷:唉你们排舞不会也是为了这个吧
Liu Ting: Hey, were you practicing for this?
Alice: 没排成 没排成
Alice: We couldn't get it right, couldn't get it right.
刘婷:啊
Liu Ting: Ah.
Alice: 排了一下午
Alice: Practiced all afternoon.
Alice: 他跳得比较好我不行
Alice: He dances better, I can't.
女嘉宾:这个背景真的很劣宗
Female Guest: This background is really bad.
女嘉宾:不觉得吗哈哈
Female Guest: Don't you think so? Haha.
Shure的女友:当然了不然呢
Shure's GF: Of course, what else?
Shure的女友:怎么了你不想
Shure's GF: What's wrong, you don't want to?
Alice: 好甜
Alice: So sweet.
Alice:开嗑
Alice: Let's start.
女嘉宾:这个背景特别劣宗
Female Guest: This background is particularly inferior.
女嘉宾:你要是单独一个人坐在那就是后彩
Female Guest: If you were sitting there alone, it would be a disaster.
女嘉宾:直接问你有哪位心动女嘉宾
Female Guest: Just ask which female guest you're interested in.
女嘉宾:然后什么给谁发了短信
Female Guest: And then ask who you texted.
Jack: 可以啊
Jack: Sure.
Jake: 是是是
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
女嘉宾:然后说你的
Female Guest: Then say your...
Jack: 怎么玩
Jack: How to play?
女嘉宾:x没有选择你
Female Guest: X didn't choose you.
Jack: 可以啊可以啊
Jack: Sure, sure.
Alice: 你真漂亮
Alice: You are really beautiful.
Alice: 我是不是太直白了
Alice: Am I being too blunt?
刘婷:你说什么
Liu Ting: What did you say?
Alice: 干嘛
Alice: What?
Alice: 翻白眼干嘛
Alice: Why are you rolling your eyes?
刘婷:没翻白眼
Liu Ting: I didn't roll my eyes.
女嘉宾:嚯所以意思就是他配不上对吧
Female Guest: So the implication is he doesn't deserve it, right?
Jack: 来来来想想拍氛围感的
Jack: Come on, come on, think about creating an atmospheric shot.
刘婷:我没说话
Liu Ting: I didn't say anything.
Alice: 我没说话
Alice: I didn't say anything.
刘婷:我跟你说
Liu Ting: I'm telling you.
刘婷:你看看你
Liu Ting: Look at yourself.
女嘉宾:当他呃就是
Female Guest: When he, uh, just...
Jack: 想想拍氛围感的可以可以那个
Jack: Think about creating an atmospheric shot, it could be good.
刘婷:口不择言
Liu Ting: Speaking thoughtlessly.
刘婷:童颜无忌 童言无忌
Liu Ting: Kids say the darndest things.
Alice:童言无忌
Alice: Kids say the darndest things.
Alice: 我比你大
Alice: I'm older than you.
Alice: 我是你姐
Alice: I'm your elder sister.
Alice: 我童言无忌
Alice: I can say whatever I want.
刘婷:噫
Liu Ting: Ew.
Alice: 没大没小
Alice: No respect for elders.
女嘉宾:噫
Female Guest: Ew.
Alice: 倒返天罡
Alice: Chaos.
Alice: 快点我们俩能合照一张吗
Alice: Hurry up, can we take a photo together?
Alice: 我我想跟她合照
Alice: I want to take a picture with her.
Alice: 有一张很有爱的
Alice: A very loving one.
刘婷:什么叫很有
Liu Ting: What do you mean by very loving?
Alice: 表情给我管理好
Alice: Keep your expression in check.
Alice:来
Alice: Come on.
Shure的女友:我不想逛大学不想逛
Shure's GFa: I don't want to walk around the university, I don't want to.
Shure的女友:我不想逛
Shure's GFa: I don't want to walk around.
刘婷:一定要带着眼镜吗
Liu Ting: Do I have to wear glasses?
Alice: 对
Alice: Yes.
女嘉宾:雌雄双煞一样
Female Guest: You two look like a pair of villains.
女嘉宾:你们俩干什么呢
Female Guest: What are you guys doing?
Jack: 黑白双煞 黑白双煞
Jack: Black and white duo, black and white duo.
Alice: 快点
Alice: Hurry up.
Alice: 这墙是
Alice: This wall is...
Alice:没动作啊
Alice: No movement, huh?
女嘉宾:哇
Female Guest: Wow.
Alice: 能不能搂着我呀来
Alice: Can you put your arm around me? Come on.
Jack: 那边叫神仙眷侣这边叫黑白双煞
Jack: Over there, they're called a perfect couple, here we're the black and white duo.
Alice: 哈哈来吧
Alice: Haha, come on.
Alice:来吧
Alice: Come on.
女嘉宾:啊 我
Female Guest: Ah, I...
Alice: 好僵硬
Alice: So stiff.
女嘉宾:是我的
Female Guest: It's mine.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha.
Jack: 对被迫营业啊
Jack: Yeah, forced to do this.
女嘉宾:太难看了
Female Guest: So ugly.
Jack: 这个这个这个这个这叫被迫营业啊
Jack: This, this, this, this is called being forced to do this.
Jack: 这个叫被迫营业啊
Jack: This is called being forced to do this.
Alice:一看就不是真情侣知道吗
Alice: You can tell they're not a real couple, you know?
Jack: 这个这个叫黑白双煞
Jack: This, this is called the black and white duo.
刘婷:什么 这个真情侣不完蛋了吗
Liu Ting: What? If this were a real couple, they'd be doomed.
Alice:我真笑死
Alice: I'm really dying of laughter.
Jack: 上面在写个匾
Jack: Write a plaque above.
女嘉宾:ok
Female Guest: Okay.
Jack: 被迫营业啊黑白双煞
Jack: Forced to do this, black and white duo.
Jack: 然后
Jack: And then...
Jack: 哎  哎
Jack: Hey, hey.
Jack: 画风突变
Jack: The style suddenly changes.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice:这才真情侣
Alice: This is a real couple.
刘婷:男士没了
Liu Ting: The guy's gone.
Alice:跟你就拍不出这种感觉
Alice: With you, we can't capture this feeling.
刘婷:因为我们本来就是就是
Liu Ting: Because we originally are...
Alice:低智哈哈哈
Alice: Dumb, hahaha
刘婷:契约
Liu Ting: Contract
Alice: 哈哈哈啊
Alice: Hahaha
刘婷:就是行婚你知道吗
Liu Ting: It's a marriage of convenience, you know?
Alice:我靠 谁跟你行婚
Alice: Damn, who wants a marriage of convenience with you?
Alice:我行婚都不想跟你行婚你去死吧你啊
Alice: Even if I wanted a marriage of convenience, I wouldn't want it with you. Go to hell.
Alice:来低智
Alice: Come on, dumb
Alice:我现在就来驯服我的手脚
Alice: I'm gonna tame my hands and feet now
Alice:没耳机啊
Alice: No headphones?
刘婷:这个动作会
Liu Ting: This move will...
Alice:低智
Alice: Dumb
女嘉宾:我也是四肢不齐
Female Guest: My limbs are uneven too
Alice:给我备注全名
Alice: Add my full name
刘婷:哎这个如何
Liu Ting: Hey, how about this?
Alice: 给我 我靠 太难了
Alice: Give it to me. Damn, it's too hard.
女嘉宾:好弱智的小视频
Female Guest: Such a dumb little video
Katrina: 那我要带眼睛
Katrina: Then I need to wear glasses
Alice:他天天给我发这个
Alice: He sends me this every day
刘婷:挺好玩的这个
Liu Ting: It's pretty fun
Alice:我靠 看不懂
Alice: Damn, I don't get it
刘婷:这是
Liu Ting: This is...
Alice:我不要跟你跳这个
Alice: I don't want to dance this with you
Alice:我这机器掉了我给你说啊你今天你就走不了了
Alice: If I drop this machine, I'm telling you, you can't leave today
刘婷:你还挑 ok ok
Liu Ting: You're still picking, ok, ok
刘婷:这个
Liu Ting: This one
Alice:我要这个
Alice: I want this one
Alice:学不会啊
Alice: Can't learn it
刘婷:左人 右 左右各一个人
Liu Ting: Left person, right, one person on each side
Shure: 后期这边全打码
Shure: Blur everything in post-production
Alice:你能教我吗
Alice: Can you teach me?
Alice:我觉得他不会
Alice: I don't think he can
女嘉宾:不行 接受不了你们俩个人
Female Guest: No way, I can't handle you two
Shure的女友:我也想问啊
Shure's GF: I want to ask too
Shure:  没事那你给贡献一下也是可以的
Shure: It's fine, you can contribute too
刘婷:兄弟兄弟
Liu Ting: Brother, brother
Alice:没兄弟了
Alice: No more brothers
Alice:你问我问Lucia跳不跳
Alice: You ask me to ask Lucia if she wants to dance
Alice: Lucia
Lucia:啊 找我吗
Lucia: Huh, are you calling me?
Alice:你想参加我们的低智小视频吗
Alice: Do you want to join our dumb little video?
Lucia:什么低智小视频
Lucia: What a dumb video.
Alice:来来来 你让她看
Alice: Come on, come on, let her see.
女嘉宾:等一下我把这个连上
Female Guest: Wait a minute, let me connect this.
Alice: 声音放大
Alice: Turn up the volume.
Jake: 这样你们这段声音可以闭掉是吧
Jake: So you guys can mute this part, right?
女嘉宾:最后最后
Female Guest: Last one, last one.
Lucia:哇 这个转圈好厉害哦
Lucia: Wow, this spinning is amazing.
Lucia:你们怎么做到了
Lucia: How did you do it?
Lucia:怎么拍的时候刚好边上没人呢
Lucia: How come there was no one around when you filmed it?
Alice:巧合
Alice: Coincidence.
刘婷:退后 左右左往右跳步然后
Liu Ting: Step back, left, right, left, then jump to the right.
Lucia:哇
Lucia: Wow.
男嘉宾:咱俩聊聊
Male Guest: Let's have a chat.
Lucia:哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, that's awesome.
Alice:受不了了
Alice: I can't take it anymore.
刘婷:要加入我们吗
Liu Ting: Want to join us?
Lucia:可以啊
Lucia: Sure.
刘婷:快 你学好吗
Liu Ting: Hurry, have you learned it?
Lucia: 我们那天跳舞应该找他们的哦
Lucia: We should have asked them for our dance the other day.
Alice: 怎么记住啊
Alice: How do you remember it?
Alice:不是我们 是他这种低智视频
Alice: Not us, it's his dumb video.
女嘉宾:别别不要给我乱戴帽子
Female Guest: No, no, don't put labels on me.
Alice: 祖奶
Alice: Grandma.
Jake: 来来来我要看我要看
Jake: Come on, come on, I want to see.
Jake: 导演把导演版拿出来
Jake: Director, bring out the director's cut.
刘婷:拍低智 过来 行
Liu Ting: Shoot the dumb video, come over, okay.
女嘉宾:让他
Female Guest: Let him.
Alice:让他拍哈哈哈哈
Alice: Let him shoot, hahaha.
Alice:干嘛
Alice: What are you doing?
Alice:能不能教教我呀 我记不住
Alice: Can you teach me? I can't remember.
刘婷:没事
Liu Ting: It's okay.
刘婷:背对着他
Liu Ting: Turn your back to him.
Alice: 背对着他 背对啊
Alice: Turn your back to him, turn your back.
刘婷:背对着他
Liu Ting: Turn your back to him.
刘婷:然后
Liu Ting: Then.
其他它:感觉堵了
Alice:这样啊哈哈哈哈
Alice: Like this, hahaha.
刘婷:在
Liu Ting: In.
刘婷:后退 等一下
Liu Ting: Step back, wait a second.
刘婷:ok
Liu Ting: OK.
Alice:这样
Alice: Like this
刘婷:这样 然后你直到啊一声
Liu Ting: Like this, and then you go "Ah"
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
刘婷:开始
Liu Ting: Start
女嘉宾:起事
Female Guest: Begin
Lucia:起
Lucia: Go
Lucia:这是咱今天晚上保留节目吗
Lucia: Is this our regular evening program?
刘婷:对 然后你
Liu Ting: Yes, and then you
刘婷:呃
Liu Ting: Uh
Alice:不是
Alice: No
刘婷:这是我们的
Liu Ting: This is our
Jack: 可以是可以是
Jack: It can be, it can be
Alice:别
Alice: Don't
Jake: 挺好挺好的
Jake: It's pretty good, pretty good
刘婷:AI识别不出来了怎么办
Liu Ting: What if the AI can't recognize it?
Shure的女友:所以你明天是只要
Shure's GF: So you just need to
Shure: 这才八月
Shure: It's only August
Jake: 最好让它识别出来对
Jake: It's best to make sure it can recognize it, yeah
刘婷:ok 你就就就是最后面那个人
Liu Ting: Okay, you just need to be the last person
刘婷:然后我们前面有两个人
Liu Ting: And then we have two people in front
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm
刘婷:然后这个之后我们就 双臂展开
Liu Ting: And after this, we spread our arms
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
刘婷:抓紧 你知道吧
Liu Ting: Hold tight, you know
刘婷:展开展开我忘  我忘  我也忘了 应该是
Liu Ting: Spread out, spread out, I forgot, I forgot, I also forgot, it should be
Katrina: 就没找过我了
Katrina: They haven't contacted me
刘婷:然后 右 左
Liu Ting: Then, right, left
Katrina:  还没怎么去了解呢
Katrina: I haven't really looked into it
刘婷:右左
Liu Ting: Right, left
Katrina:  我应该是做容器那一块
Katrina: I should be working on the container part
刘婷:然后
Liu Ting: Then
Alice: 不是 这什么时候出 什么时候收啊
Alice: No, when do we go out, when do we come back?
刘婷:协调一点嘛
Liu Ting: Coordinate a bit
Alice: 不协调啊
Alice: It's not coordinated
刘婷:左 右
Liu Ting: Left, right
刘婷:左
Liu Ting: Left
Alice: 不是这什么时候出什么时候收
Alice: No, when do we go out, when do we come back?
刘婷:来 come on
Liu Ting: Come on
刘婷:起 右 左
Liu Ting: Up, right, left
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Alice: 哎呀懂了
Alice: Ah, I get it.
刘婷:左右踏步
Liu Ting: Step left and right.
Alice: 这不是踏步
Alice: This isn't stepping.
Alice: 这不是扭腿吗
Alice: Isn't this twisting your leg?
Shure: 吓死我以为你说小朋友是是我
Shure: You scared me, I thought you said the kid was me.
Alice: 啊我觉得太抽象了
Alice: Ah, I think it's too abstract.
刘婷:那就是
Liu Ting: Then it's...
Alice: 不行不行还是要这个
Alice: No, no, we still need this.
Alice:啊 不是这个
Alice: Ah, not this.
刘婷:拍之前那个嫌难度高
Liu Ting: The one before was too difficult.
刘婷:拍这哎
Liu Ting: Shoot this, hey.
Alice: 哎呀 不难 我学
Alice: Ah, it's not hard, I'll learn.
刘婷:踏步准备
Liu Ting: Prepare to step.
刘婷:然后对对对
Liu Ting: Then yes, yes, yes.
刘婷:他们归位之后就左右哈哈哈
Liu Ting: After they return to their spots, step left and right, hahaha.
Alice: 猫眼三姐妹
Alice: Cat's Eye Sisters.
刘婷:如何学如何了
Liu Ting: How's the learning going?
Alice:学不
Alice: Not learning.
Alice:我再记一会
Alice: I'll remember it later.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
刘婷:来给我背一遍啊
Liu Ting: Come on, recite it for me.
刘婷:背过去
Liu Ting: Recite it.
Alice:背过去
Alice: Recite it.
Alice:起 起事 右 左 右 左 踏步
Alice: Ready, right, left, right, left, step.
男嘉宾:看来她们后面要跳舞
Male Guest: Looks like they're going to dance later.
女嘉宾:这个不行
Female Guest: This won't work.
Lucia:你这个入镜的刚好都是些可乐和酒
Lucia: The frame just caught some cola and alcohol.
Alice:然后 你 回来
Alice: Then you come back.
Alice:我
Alice: I...
Alice:这今晚上能练会这个吗
Alice: Can we practice this tonight?
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
刘婷:实在不行咱还是跳舞吧
Liu Ting: If it really doesn't work, let's dance.
Alice:不行你太弱智
Alice: No, you're too dumb.
Lucia:你本来就这么大
Lucia: You were already this big.
Lucia:哈哈不是我摄影技术问题
Lucia: Haha, it's not my photography skills.
刘婷:左右左右左分散
Liu Ting: Left, right, left, right, spread out.
Alice: 我又不用分散
Alice: I don't need to spread out.
Lucia:跑了相机不好相相机没拍出你的这个
Lucia: The camera ran out, didn't capture your...
Lucia:这个这个英姿飒爽是吧
Lucia: Your heroic posture, right?
Lucia:哈哈哈 这咋 哎
Lucia: Hahaha, what, hey.
Lucia:相机没拍出你的英姿飒爽
Lucia: The camera didn't capture your heroic and spirited look.
刘婷:起右左右左踏步
Liu Ting: Step right, left, right, left.
刘婷:这不关你的事
Liu Ting: It's none of your business.
Alice: 啊这个哈哈哈哈
Alice: Ah, this hahaha.
刘婷:这个哈哈
Liu Ting: This hahaha.
刘婷:你 你不是这个苗子我天呢
Liu Ting: You, you are not the right candidate, oh my.
刘婷:如何
Liu Ting: How is it?
女嘉宾:特别好
Female Guest: Very good.
Alice:好像学会了又好像没学会
Alice: It seems like you learned it, but also didn't.
Alice: 你你要不要参与我们
Alice: Do you want to join us?
Alice:脸 哈哈哈Lucia你来嘛
Alice: Face, hahaha. Lucia, come on.
Alice: 我是摸屁股这个
Alice: I'm the one who touches the butt.
Alice: 哈哈哈不是哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha, no hahaha.
Alice:你是哈哈那个
Alice: You are the hahaha one.
刘婷:这是不是太近了
Liu Ting: Isn't this too close?
Lucia:如何一句话劝退别人是吗
Lucia: Is it how to dissuade someone in one sentence?
Jake: 让我整这个
Jake: Let me handle this.
Katrina:  哈哈哈还有还有助理帮你调整
Katrina: Hahaha, and there's also an assistant to help you adjust.
Alice:哎呦哎呦
Alice: Oh, oh.
刘婷:ok 来来来来
Liu Ting: Ok, come on, come on.
刘婷:我看下这个距离
Liu Ting: Let me check this distance.
Shure: 哈哈哈 他他有可能烧的
Shure: Hahaha, he might burn it.
Shure:  还没没有反应过来
Shure: Still hasn't reacted yet.
刘婷:或者我们投票吧
Liu Ting: Or should we vote?
Shure的女友:你别扇别扇别扇别扇别扇
Shure's GF: Don't fan, don't fan, don't fan, don't fan, don't fan.
刘婷:就是可能会伤害他的眼睛
Liu Ting: It might hurt his eyes.
Lucia:伤害他的眼镜 啊 OK
Lucia: Hurt his glasses, ah, OK.
Alice: 就这样蹦来蹦去吗
Alice: Just hopping around like this?
Alice: 我连个兜都没有
Alice: I don't even have a pocket.
Alice: 这别我腰上的
Alice: This is tied to my waist.
刘婷:拿着  还有一个就是这个
Liu Ting: Hold this. And there's also this one.
Lucia:啊 不过这个就是容易掉下来
Lucia: Ah, but this one easily falls off.
Alice:他抖音上全是这种低智小视频
Alice: His TikTok is full of low-intelligence short videos.
刘婷:对像你
Liu Ting: Yeah, like you.
Lucia:那刚那个人是你吗
Lucia: Was that person you just now?
刘婷:不是这是我网
Liu Ting: No, this is my internet...
刘婷:哦我网上收集的低智数据
Liu Ting: Oh, I collected low-intelligence data online.
Lucia:OK
Lucia: OK.
Alice: 低智太奶这就是
Alice: Low-intelligence is just like this.
Shure的女友:不是
Shure's GF: No.
刘婷:就是他先起来
Liu Ting: He gets up first.
Katrina:  哦哦对
Katrina: Oh, oh right.
刘婷:然后我们后面剩下左右左
Liu Ting: Then we follow, left, right, left.
Alice:这样
Alice: Like this.
刘婷:然后到位踏步
Liu Ting: Then march in place.
Lucia:迅速进入角色
Lucia: Quickly get into character.
刘婷:你看你看
Liu Ting: Look, look.
刘婷:无所谓拍的好不好无所谓
Liu Ting: It doesn't matter if it's filmed well or not.
刘婷:重在参与好不好 重在参与
Liu Ting: What's important is participation.
刘婷:有信心吗
Liu Ting: Do you have confidence?
Lucia:没有
Lucia: No.
刘婷:没有我不
Liu Ting: No, I don't...
Shure: 嗨 这都是我们配的一环
Shure: Hey, this is all part of our collaboration.
刘婷:你要有
Liu Ting: You need to have it.
Alice:有
Alice: Yes, I do.
Lucia:响亮的答案没有
Lucia: Loud and clear, I don't.
刘婷:要有要有要有
Liu Ting: You need to, you need to.
刘婷:OK我们看一下我们看一下
Liu Ting: OK, let's take a look.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jack: 准备好啦
Jack: Ready?
Katrina:  我想拿这个拍照
Katrina: I want to take a photo with this.
Lucia:我们没有
Lucia: We don't have...
Katrina:  哈哈哈我可以拿他那个给我拍照
Katrina: Hahaha, can I use his camera to take a photo?
Katrina:  你给我看
Katrina: Show me.
Jack: 可以啊
Jack: Sure.
刘婷:你看一下位置
Liu Ting: Check the position.
Katrina:  靖康导师导师我可以拿这个拍张照吗
Katrina: Instructor Jingkang, can I take a photo with this?
刘婷:这这这那
Liu Ting: This, this, and that.
Alice:那我不就是最明显的那个了
Alice: Then I'd be the most noticeable one.
刘婷:我我我侧面侧侧过来侧过来
Liu Ting: I'll move to the side, move to the side.
Katrina: 哈哈哈看哪光好
Katrina: Hahaha, look where the light is good.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
刘婷:侧过来就是我可以站稍微远一点吗
Liu Ting: Move to the side, can I stand a bit farther?
Jake: 可以打光要不要搬出来
Jake: Should we bring out the lights?
Jack: 那可以
Jack: That works.
刘婷:哎呦 不对哦
Liu Ting: Oh no, that's not right.
Alice: 那这边不就没地了
Alice: Then there won't be any space here.
刘婷:你的眼睛呢
Liu Ting: Where are your eyes?
Katrina:  这光好吗面这
Katrina: Is this light good?
Shure:  你喊我给你送东西
Shure: Call me if you need me to bring something.
Shure:  然后你说你放在那个男生宿舍就行
Shure: And then you said you can leave it in the boys' dormitory.
刘婷:OK来看下准备
Liu Ting: OK, let's take a look and get ready.
Alice:行了吗
Alice: Are we good to go?
Shure的女友:我没有我不
Shure's GF: I didn't, I don't...
刘婷:OK差不多
Liu Ting: OK, almost there.
Shure的女友:我印象我没有碰到你
Shure's GF: I don't remember running into you.
刘婷:来来来
Liu Ting: Come on, come on.
Shure的女友:那次是因为我们当时社会实践
Shure's GF: That time it was because we were doing social practice.
刘婷:差不多然然后你咱咱分散开
Liu Ting: Almost there, then let's split up.
Shure的女友:然后要开个会嘛
Shure's GF: And we had to hold a meeting.
Shure的女友:然后整个组的话是只有我跟培训员
Shure's GF: The whole team was just me and the trainer.
刘婷:你左边一个
Liu Ting: One on your left.
刘婷:我右边一个
Liu Ting: One on my right.
刘婷:你往那边走
Liu Ting: Move over a bit.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈我是导演
Katrina: Hahaha, I'm the director.
刘婷:走一点点
Liu Ting: Just a little bit.
Shure的女友:我们两个女生
Shure's GF: It was just the two of us girls.
Lucia:这样
Lucia: Like this.
刘婷:对啊可以能拍到
Liu Ting: Yeah, that's good, we can capture it.
Alice:来吧
Alice: Let's go.
刘婷:嗯 我想想嗯OK OK
Liu Ting: Hmm, let me think... OK, OK.
刘婷:我们先熟悉的伴奏好不好好
Liu Ting: Let's get familiar with the accompaniment first, okay?
Shure的女友:反正我那个头发无所谓了
Shure's GF: Anyway, my hair doesn't matter anymore.
Alice: 好
Alice: Alright.
Katrina:  哇哦哈哈哈
Katrina: Wow, haha.
Lucia:哇哦哈哈
Lucia: Wow, haha.
Alice: 我天天拍这种低智视频
Alice: I shoot these dumb videos every day.
Shure的女友:然后就完全可以去
Shure's GF: And then we could totally go.
Alice:他的座右铭就是看低智视频
Alice: His motto is watching dumb videos.
Alice:想低智人生
Alice: Living a dumb life.
Lucia:哈哈我以为是享高智人生呢
Lucia: Haha, I thought it was living a smart life.
Alice:哈哈我以为是想高智人生
Alice: Haha, I thought it was living a smart life.
Jack: 你们难道你们并不是
Jack: Aren't you guys...
Katrina:  我们太随便了
Katrina: We're too casual.
Katrina:  我以为第一天很正式
Katrina: I thought the first day would be very formal.
刘婷:6来来来合并
Liu Ting: Come on, come together.
Shure的女友:然后都要过来啊
Shure's GF: Everyone needs to come over.
Lucia:先合并是吧
Lucia: So, we merge first?
刘婷:321
Liu Ting: 3, 2, 1.
刘婷:开始
Liu Ting: Start.
Alice:是这样吗
Alice: Is it like this?
Jake: 就这样录一下你们祥是哈哈哈哈
Jake: Just record it like this, you guys haha
Lucia:然后下一个是我是吧
Lucia: Then it's my turn next, right?
Lucia:啊这样子
Lucia: Ah, like this
Lucia:然后还是接着动啊哈哈
Lucia: And keep moving, haha
Alice: 玩不了一点哈哈哈
Alice: Can't play at all, haha
刘婷:存个草稿
Liu Ting: Save a draft
Jake: 呃我拉插线板会长一点
Jake: Uh, I'll pull the power strip, it will be longer
Alice:看看
Alice: Let's see
Jack: 他色温可以调吗
Jack: Can the color temperature be adjusted?
Jake:我不会了
Jake: I can't do it
Jake: 他很便宜啊
Jake: It's very cheap
Jack: 那就这样了
Jack: Then it's fine like this
Jake: 好嘞 能强点是吧
Jake: Okay, can it be stronger?
Jack: 不是 色温可以重新
Jack: No, the color temperature can be adjusted again
刘婷:存草稿吧存草稿
Liu Ting: Save the draft, save the draft
Alice:哎呦 我笑死了
Alice: Oh, I'm dying of laughter
女嘉宾:再来一遍
Female Guest: Do it again
刘婷:有信心吗
Liu Ting: Are you confident?
Lucia:没有
Lucia: No
Alice:没
Alice: No
Lucia:响亮的答复 没有
Lucia: Loud answer, no
Alice:没有我们先休息一会
Alice: No, let's take a break first
Alice: 不急于一时
Alice: No rush
刘婷:行 没事
Liu Ting: Sure, no problem
Alice: 反正有个草稿了
Alice: At least we have a draft
刘婷:我们
Liu Ting: We
刘婷:我们有这一个版其实已经很不错了
Liu Ting: Having this version is already pretty good
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yes
Alice:很不错了
Alice: It's pretty good
刘婷:至少有勇气站在这舞台上了
Liu Ting: At least we had the courage to stand on this stage
Lucia:是
Lucia: Yes
Alice: 确实如果你不在
Alice: Indeed, if you weren't here
Alice: 我是绝对不会站在这里丢人的
Alice: I would never stand here and embarrass myself
Alice: 但是我跟你一起丢人就没有
Alice: But if I'm embarrassing myself with you, then it's not
刘婷:你特么
Liu Ting: You...
Alice: 就没有那么丢人
Alice: It's not that embarrassing
Shure的女友:啊没了就剩这些了
Shure's GF: Ah, that's all that's left
刘婷:修饰一下你语言修饰一下你语言啊
Liu Ting: Watch your language, watch your language
刘婷:怎么能这样呢
Liu Ting: How can you say that?
Alice: 羞耻
Alice: Shameful.
Lucia:怎么能这样呢
Lucia: How could this happen?
Lucia:说的好像我不愿意跟你一起丢人一样
Lucia: It's like I don't want to be embarrassed with you.
Alice:哈哈哈但是我不愿意拉你一起丢人
Alice: Hahaha, but I don't want to drag you down with me.
Alice:但是丢人的话我觉得就可以
Alice: But if it's just me, it's fine.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
刘婷:我受够了
Liu Ting: I've had enough.
Jack: 哎呀这是什么剧情啊
Jack: Oh, what kind of plot is this?
Lucia:等一下我手里有张纸
Lucia: Wait, I have a piece of paper.
Lucia:要不要比个心
Lucia: How about we make a heart?
Lucia:我们俩这样
Lucia: Like this, the two of us.
Jack: ：这个可能要打点光效果就好了
Jack: Maybe we need some lighting for this.
Alice:背光了
Alice: We're backlit.
刘婷:你们眼镜上面有光
Liu Ting: There's light on your glasses.
Jack: 实际上眼镜上泛着那
Jack: Actually, it's reflecting off the glasses.
Alice: 那那我们这样
Alice: Then how about this...
Lucia:眼睛上泛着诡异的光
Lucia: Your glasses are reflecting weirdly.
女嘉宾:眼镜上面有光
Female Guest: There's light on the glasses.
Lucia:可还行
Lucia: It's okay.
Lucia:哪边
Lucia: Which side?
Alice:好
Alice: Alright.
Alice:来吧
Alice: Let's do it.
Katrina:  一起播
Katrina: Let's broadcast together.
Alice:来吧
Alice: Come on.
Katrina:  我们一起拍 拍拍
Katrina: Let's film this together.
Lucia:可
Lucia: Sure.
Alice:来
Alice: Let's go.
Katrina: 我 拿这个咱信就是演员
Katrina: With this, we are true actors.
Alice: 怎怎么摆
Alice: How do we pose?
Katrina:  我们仨
Katrina: The three of us.
Alice:比心
Alice: Make a heart.
Lucia:可以可以
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Lucia:交叉比等一下
Lucia: Cross arms, wait.
Alice: 我是危险中心
Alice: I'm in the danger zone.
Lucia:手里一直揣着这个
Lucia: Hold this the whole time.
Katrina: 我也加入
Katrina: I'll join too.
Lucia:刚才擦手用餐巾纸擦
Lucia: Just wiped my hands with a napkin.
Lucia:咱俩还可以这样
Lucia: We can do this, the two of us.
Lucia:算了有点乱了
Lucia: Never mind, it's getting messy.
Alice: 有点抽象
Alice: It's a bit abstract.
Lucia:等一下我扶一下眼镜
Lucia: Wait a second, let me adjust my glasses.
Lucia:我这眼镜往下滑
Lucia: My glasses keep sliding down.
Katrina: 这光补光打出来啥样
Katrina: How's the lighting now?
Alice:累了
Alice: Tired.
Lucia:哎这个光很好
Lucia: Oh, this light is really good.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Alice: 那你现在回去的话
Alice: So if you go back now...
Alice:自己行吗要不我去送你
Alice: Can you manage on your own? Should I take you?
女嘉宾:可以
Female Guest: It's fine.
刘婷:噢
Liu Ting: Oh.
女嘉宾:一会伸手不见五指
Female Guest: It will be pitch dark soon.
Lucia:after party
Lucia: After party.
Lucia:不是不是修硕要
Lucia: No, no, Shure wants...
Shure的女友:没有点正经音乐
Shure's GF: No proper music?
Alice:你要从这到那要多久
Alice: How long will it take from here to there?
Katrina:  啊修硕 唱歌
Katrina: Ah, Shure, sing a song.
女嘉宾:从哪到哪
Female Guest: From where to where?
Alice: 就是你坐你的公交公共交通
Alice: Like when you take the public transport.
女嘉宾:十来分钟吧
Female Guest: About ten minutes.
Lucia:不是修硕要干好多事来着吗
Lucia: Isn't Shure supposed to do a lot of things?
Alice:哦那还好
Alice: Oh, that's not too bad.
Katrina:  哈哈哈核心主力吗
Katrina: Haha, the main player?
Alice:累吗哎等下下
Alice: Are you tired? Hold on.
Shure:  我怕回去他不认我了
Shure: I'm afraid he won't recognize me when I get back.
Katrina: 哈哈你跳个舞她也跟你和好了
Katrina: Haha, just dance for her, and she'll forgive you.
Alice:OK
Alice: OK.
Shure: 他分在哪跳啊
Shure: Where should I dance?
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Alice:挤眉弄眼的干什么
Alice: Why are you making faces?
Shure的女友:哎 你别说他小时候学过
Shure's GF: Hey, don't say that, he learned it as a kid.
Katrina:  他学什么舞种
Katrina: What kind of dance?
Alice:好神经啊
Alice: So weird.
Shure的女友:你问他咯
Shure's GF: Ask him.
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Tasha:我什么都没干我在
Tasha: I didn't do anything, I was just...
Nicous: 我们去打英雄联盟
Nicous: We're going to play League of Legends.
Tasha:真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Alice: 送你一下吧
Alice: I'll walk you back.
Alice: 我要去送他一下
Alice: I'll go take him back.
刘婷:走走走走走走走
Liu Ting: Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Alice:我去送他一下
Alice: I'll go see him off.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Jake:拜拜拜拜
Jake: Bye bye bye.
Jake:没开过
Jake: Never driven it before.
Jake:头回开
Jake: First time driving.
Alice:开过 但忘了
Alice: I've driven it, but I forgot.
Shure: 怎么啦
Shure: What's up?
Shure的女友:他刚刚已经没理我
Shure's GF: He just ignored me.
Alice:走了
Alice: He's gone.
刘婷:哦哟 慢点慢点
Liu Ting: Oh, slow down, slow down.
Alice:那我就录着这个走啦
Alice: Then I'll just record this.
Jake:好好好
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Alice:拜拜
Alice: Bye-bye.
Jake:拜拜拜拜
Jake: Bye bye bye.
Alice:能给我开个热点吗
Alice: Can you give me a hotspot?
刘婷:啊
Liu Ting: Huh?
Alice: 是的 不太够
Alice: Yeah, it's not enough.
刘婷:零几的
Liu Ting: What model?
Alice:啊
Alice: Huh?
Alice:我连个热点
Alice: I need a hotspot.
女嘉宾:现在7.30了
Female Guest: It's 7:30 now.
刘婷:哎哎哎
Liu Ting: Hey, hey, hey.
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Alice: 你叫什么
Alice: What's your name?
Alice:脚指盖
Alice: Toenail.
刘婷:你之前连过了
Liu Ting: You've connected before.
Alice:妈的 烦
Alice: Damn, annoying.
Alice:让我多刷点你的流量
Alice: Let me use more of your data.
Alice:不占点你的便宜我难受我跟你讲
Alice: I feel bad if I don't take advantage of you, I'm telling you.
Alice:咋
Alice: What?
刘婷:哦咪咪
Liu Ting: Oh, Mimi.
Alice:哪有咪咪啊
Alice: Where's Mimi?
刘婷:嗨咪咪
Liu Ting: Hi, Mimi.
Alice:咪咪
Alice: Mimi.
Alice:狗狗
Alice: Doggie.
Alice:边牧
Alice: Border collie.
Alice:聪明狗
Alice: Smart dog.
Alice:聪明狗狗
Alice: Smart doggie.
女嘉宾:狗狗说旁边那个两脚兽好奇怪啊
Female Guest: The dog says that biped over there is so weird.
刘婷:哈哈聪明狗就很聪明啊
Liu Ting: Haha, a smart dog is really smart.
Alice:就是很聪明啊
Alice: It's just really smart.
Alice:我们
Alice: We...
Alice:你俩加个联系方式不得了
Alice: You two should exchange contact information.
Alice:咋啦
Alice: What's up?
Alice:他不在了吧
Alice: Is he gone?
Alice:哦在在在摸鱼群摸鱼群
Alice: Oh, he's in the chill group, the chill group.
女嘉宾:追追那个团吗
Female Guest: Are you chasing that group?
女嘉宾:对  哎
Female Guest: Yes, yeah.
女嘉宾:或者是那个有追过
Female Guest: Or did you chase it before?
女嘉宾:之前
Female Guest: Before...
女嘉宾:追相见嗯
Female Guest: Chasing to meet, hmm.
女嘉宾:我觉得这花名起的这么神经
Female Guest: I think this nickname is so silly.
Jack: 那个灰鸟灰得什么情况笑场
Jack: What's up with that gray bird laughing?
Alice:那我们三个人出来玩呀
Alice: Then let's hang out, the three of us.
Alice:你俩还能聊一块吗
Alice: Can you two even chat?
女嘉宾:嗯然后你就变成小三
Female Guest: Hmm, then you'll become the third wheel.
Alice:我
Alice: I...
女嘉宾:我不被爱的才行
Female Guest: It's only if I'm not loved.
Alice:对啊不被爱的才是小三
Alice: Yeah, the unloved one is the third wheel.
Alice:你说谁才是三
Alice: Who do you think is the third wheel?
女嘉宾:OK OK
Female Guest: OK, OK.
女嘉宾:不是说嗯本来有17个人
Female Guest: Didn't they say there were 17 people originally?
女嘉宾:嗯然后变成什么13个加什么
Female Guest: Hmm, then it became 13 plus something.
女嘉宾:小分队再加个什么
Female Guest: A sub-group plus something.
女嘉宾:还有一种说法就是
Female Guest: There’s also a saying that...
女嘉宾:原来是有17个
Female Guest: There were originally 17 people.
女嘉宾:饭量太大了
Female Guest: Their appetites were too big.
女嘉宾:然后把这三个人吃掉了
Female Guest: Then they ate three people.
女嘉宾:我也听过这个说法
Female Guest: I’ve heard this saying too.
Alice:啊痛痛
Alice: Ouch, ouch.
Alice:行行别说了
Alice: Alright, alright, stop talking.
女嘉宾:平地摔都是女主才有的
Female Guest: Only the female leads trip on flat ground.
Alice: 我每一次的这种绊脚
Alice: Every time I trip, Liu Ting catches it.
Alice:都会被刘婷捕捉到我真服了
Alice: I'm really impressed.
Alice:哎从哪走啊
Alice: Hey, which way do we go?
Alice:我不知道啊
Alice:哎你好牛逼哦
Alice: Wow, you’re amazing.
女嘉宾:我还开着导航走的
Female Guest: I’m still using the GPS to walk.
女嘉宾:我还开了两次导航
Female Guest: I even used it twice.
女嘉宾:我第一次开导航
Female Guest: This is my first time using navigation.
女嘉宾:不知道给我导到哪个犄角旮旯去了
Female Guest: No idea where it’s taking me, to some random corner.
女嘉宾:然后我一看好像不对
Female Guest: Then I checked and realized it might be wrong.
女嘉宾:然后又在点拍他又他又让我再走
Female Guest: So I clicked it again and it told me to go further.
女嘉宾:再走个100多米
Female Guest: Walk another 100 meters or so.
女嘉宾:吓我一跳
Female Guest: Scared me.
Alice:咋了
Alice: What happened?
女嘉宾:他以为你没了
Female Guest: He thought you were gone.
Alice:我靠
Alice: Oh my god.
女嘉宾:哦哦
Female Guest: Oh, oh.
Alice:不能过人了吗
Alice: Can’t we pass through?
Alice:这这门还有宵禁啦
Alice: This gate has a curfew?
女嘉宾:这门还这门还有看门的
Female Guest: This gate has a guard.
女嘉宾:确实让我很意外
Female Guest: That really surprised me.
女嘉宾:就像那个景点门口的那种匝机一样
Female Guest: Like the kind of fried chicken you find at tourist spots.
Alice:炸鸡 烤鸭
Alice: Fried chicken, roast duck.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice:好好好不玩了
Alice: Alright, alright, let’s stop playing.
Alice:在也不玩抽像了
Alice: I’m done playing with abstraction.
女嘉宾:哎呀你那小狗没拿
Female Guest: Hey, you didn’t take your puppy.
女嘉宾:哦没事
Female Guest: Oh, it’s fine.
Alice:什么小狗啊
Alice: What puppy?
女嘉宾:走时候带走
Female Guest: Take it with you when you leave.
女嘉宾:我拍了你的小狗
Female Guest: I took a picture of your puppy.
刘婷:纸狗
Liu Ting: Paper puppy.
Alice:啊没事给他扔这吧
Alice: Ah, it’s fine, just leave it here.
女嘉宾:哦都揣揣兜里了
Female Guest: Oh, it’s all stuffed in my pocket.
Alice:那小狗扔那得了
Alice: Leave the puppy there.
Alice:随时能坐啊
Alice: You can sit anytime.
女嘉宾:饲养动物
Female Guest: Feeding animals.
Alice:啊 对不起对不起对不起我有罪
Alice: Ah, sorry, sorry, it’s my fault.
Alice:我下辈子在还
Alice: I’ll repay it in my next life.
Alice:你说小狗
Alice: You mean the puppy?
Alice:我寻思哪来的小狗
Alice: I was wondering where the puppy came from.
Alice:超市
Alice: Supermarket.
Alice: 刘婷想吃什么进去选购我请你吃
Alice: Liu Ting, pick whatever you want, I’ll treat you.
女嘉宾:这里离那个门这么近吗
Female Guest: Is it that close to the gate here?
女嘉宾:那我走了绕绕远路了好像是
Female Guest: Seems like I took a longer route.
刘婷:不是吧
Liu Ting: No way.
Alice:不是吧
Alice: No way.
女嘉宾:哦原来从这里进来就是那个地方
Female Guest: Oh, so coming in from here leads to that place.
女嘉宾:反正我绕了很久
Female Guest: Anyway, I went around for a long time.
女嘉宾:然后才绕到这里
Female Guest: And then finally ended up here.
女嘉宾:我可能从这里进来
Female Guest: I might have come in from here.
女嘉宾:导航给我导了错误的方向
Female Guest: The navigation gave me the wrong direction.
女嘉宾:我绕了一圈才往这边走的
Female Guest: I went in a circle before coming this way.
女嘉宾:别吧
Female Guest: No way.
Alice:啊这还有出入口呢
Alice: Ah, there's an entrance here.
女嘉宾:是啊这个
Female Guest: Yeah, this one.
女嘉宾:你不是从这
Female Guest: Didn't you come from here?
Alice:我们打车啊
Alice: We took a taxi.
女嘉宾:你OK
Female Guest: You okay?
Alice:ok ok
Alice: Okay, okay.
Alice:真没走过路姐们
Alice: Seriously, never walked here, girls.
女嘉宾:这个真的很像那个景区景区的闸门
Female Guest: This really looks like the entrance to a tourist spot.
Alice:我靠真服了
Alice: Oh my, I'm really impressed.
Alice:噢 都可以
Alice: Oh, it's all good.
女嘉宾:没事 应该可以过去
Female Guest: It's okay, we should be able to get through.
Alice: 爬叉呗
Alice: Climb over then.
女嘉宾:你从正面看
Female Guest: Look from the front.
女嘉宾:这就很像男女公厕
Female Guest: This really looks like a public restroom.
Alice:我去 我真服了
Alice: Oh my, I'm really impressed.
Alice: 这这
Alice: This, this...
女嘉宾:种村里的公厕
Female Guest: Village public restroom.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice: 这这
Alice: This, this...
Alice:行吧 你俩愿意来这确实是
Alice: Alright, if you two are willing to come here, it's really...
Alice:不是 没
Alice: No, wait...
Alice:你俩愿意来真是铁过命的交情了
Alice: You two coming here means you have a really strong bond.
女嘉宾:你怎么你怎么被人拐到村里去了
Female Guest: How did you get tricked into coming to the village?
刘婷:我的天啊
Liu Ting: Oh my god.
Alice:确实 你俩愿意来
Alice: Seriously, you two coming here...
Alice: 哎真是我太感动了
Alice: Ah, I'm really touched.
Alice: 咋办
Alice: What to do...
女嘉宾:你没有看过这
Female Guest: Have you ever seen this...
女嘉宾:这边的景象
Female Guest: This view over here?
女嘉宾:那边很繁华吗
Female Guest: Is it very bustling over there?
Alice: 不繁华呀
Alice: Not bustling.
Alice: 但是一般都
Alice: But usually...
Alice: 是那种公路的那种
Alice: It's the kind of place with a lot of roads.
Alice: 就我们坐车来的嘛
Alice: We came by car, right?
女嘉宾:不是太小这里是
Female Guest: Isn't it too small here?
Alice:哎小狗
Alice: Oh, a puppy!
Alice:干啥
Alice: What are you doing?
Alice: 行行行
Alice: Alright, alright, alright.
Alice:你就玩抽像吧刘婷
Alice: Just play abstract, Liu Ting.
Alice:你要造反似的我要告诉你
Alice: If you rebel, I'll tell you.
Alice:你吃饱了吗刘婷
Alice: Are you full, Liu Ting?
刘婷:吃饱了
Liu Ting: Yes, I'm full.
Alice:你可别做假
Alice: Don't fake it.
刘婷:我能作假
Liu Ting: How can I fake it?
Alice: 那谁知道呢
Alice: Who knows?
Alice: 行行行那鸡蛋你也吃啊
Alice: Alright, alright, so you'll eat the egg too?
Alice: 生吃 我买了可生食
Alice: Eat it raw, I bought it for raw consumption.
Alice: 鸡蛋 可以吃
Alice: The egg is edible.
Alice: 一口一个
Alice: One bite each.
女嘉宾:那你们还要出来逛超市采购
Female Guest: Then you guys still go out shopping for groceries?
Alice: 对啊
Alice: Yeah.
女嘉宾:对啊还是说你们就是美团的
Female Guest: Or are you guys just using Meituan?
Alice: 我们去盒马
Alice: We go to Hema.
Alice: 我们吃上面花的钱不少哎
Alice: We spend a lot on food.
刘婷:哎呦果然是有人报销
Liu Ting: Oh, someone is reimbursing it after all.
女嘉宾:好远
Female Guest: So far.
Alice:周三要出去玩
Alice: Going out to play on Wednesday.
Alice: 出去玩出去玩出去玩
Alice: Going out to play, going out to play, going out to play.
Alice:五一不回家了
Alice: Not going home for May Day.
Alice: 不回家了不回家
Alice: Not going home, not going home.
Alice: 你回吗
Alice: Are you going home?
女嘉宾:买票回
Female Guest: Buying a ticket to go home.
女嘉宾:买不到算了
Female Guest: If I can't get one, then forget it.
Alice: 那你现在要是还不不买的话
Alice: If you don't buy it now,
Alice: 你大概率是没了
Alice: You're very likely to miss it.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:哪玩
Alice: Where are we going?
刘婷:感觉好多天以前就说那个
Liu Ting: Feels like we mentioned it many days ago,
刘婷:五一回家票就没有了
Liu Ting: That there would be no tickets left for May Day.
刘婷:然后
Liu Ting: And then...
Alice:对啊我就再想想啊再想想
Alice: Yeah, I was just thinking, thinking.
刘婷:然后还说就是看其他软件互补结果
Liu Ting: And then we said we'd check other apps, but in the end...
Alice:谁啊你又记差人了吧
Alice: Who? You must have confused people again.
Alice:我从不用别的软件
Alice: I never use other apps.
刘婷:不是我看网上抖音说哦
Liu Ting: No, I saw on TikTok...
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
刘婷:他们不有那个什么什么铁道那个
Liu Ting: They have that railway thing...
Alice:嗯 嗯
Alice: Mm, mm.
刘婷:然后还有就是地方他们买什么携程啊
Liu Ting: And also, they buy from places like Ctrip...
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice:那不都二道贩子吗
Alice: Aren't they all just middlemen?
刘婷:对
Liu Ting: Right.
女嘉宾:这首歌到底是谁的
Female Guest: Whose song is this anyway?
刘婷:是Candy
Liu Ting: It's Candy.
刘婷:是SM之前好像是有一个男团叫浩特吧
Liu Ting: It was from an old boy band called Hot from SM, I think.
刘婷:浩特然后NCT后面
Liu Ting: Hot, and then later NCT.
女嘉宾:后面被人好像翻唱过很多次
Female Guest: It's been covered many times.
女嘉宾:被认为是他们的代表作
Female Guest: Considered one of their iconic songs.
刘婷:对对对但我记得有人说
Liu Ting: Yeah, but I remember someone said...
刘婷:好像就是很古早的一首歌
Liu Ting: It's a very old song.
刘婷:yes how how那个
Liu Ting: Yes, how, how that...
刘婷:那个dreams come这个
Liu Ting: That Dreams Come, this...
女嘉宾:一歌传3代
Female Guest: A song passed down through three generations.
Alice:歌走人还在
Alice: The song lives on, people stay.
刘婷:左边是那个车站吧
Liu Ting: The station is on the left, right?
女嘉宾:是吧我来想一下
Female Guest: Yeah, let me think.
女嘉宾:没事到这就行了
Female Guest: It's okay, this is fine.
Alice:没事 到这了也不差这两步了
Alice: It's okay, we're here, a few more steps won't hurt.
刘婷:我要看着你安安全全的上车才行
Liu Ting: I need to make sure you get on the car safely.
Alice:确实
Alice: True.
女嘉宾:从来没有来过通州
Female Guest: I've never been to Tongzhou before.
Alice:通州还挺大的
Alice: Tongzhou is quite big.
刘婷:通州不大创造神话
Liu Ting: Tongzhou isn't big, but it creates legends.
女嘉宾:我往这边走的时候
Female Guest: When I walked this way...
Alice:创造神话
女嘉宾:我往这边走的时候就想起来那个故里
Female Guest: When I walked this way, I remembered the homeland.
女嘉宾:他说什么
Female Guest: What did he say?
女嘉宾:我一道普哈哈
Female Guest: I laughed out loud.
女嘉宾:过敏出了
Female Guest: Allergies came out.
Alice:出了什么几环
Alice: Came out of which ring road.
Alice:对这空气过敏
Alice: Yeah, allergic to the air here.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
刘婷:感觉这个北京好陌生哈哈哈
Liu Ting: This Beijing feels so unfamiliar, hahaha
刘婷:尤其是大航
Liu Ting: Especially Da Hang
刘婷:我坐公交时候还穿过好几条河
Liu Ting: I even crossed several rivers while taking the bus
刘婷:我甚至一度以为我已经去北京了
Liu Ting: At one point, I even thought I had arrived in Beijing
Alice:牛
Alice: Impressive
女嘉宾:北京最大北京
Female Guest: Beijing is the biggest Beijing
Alice:北京
Alice: Beijing
Alice:嗯好
Alice: Hmm, okay
Alice:没事等车来吧
Alice: No worries, let's wait for the car
Alice:我感觉要是不想上班的话我就辞了
Alice: I feel like if I don't want to work, I'll just quit
Alice:然后我就4月20多我就回家了
Alice: Then I'll go home around April 20th
Alice:然后等到七八号的再来
Alice: And come back around the 7th or 8th
Alice:也可以回去上两天班看看感觉
Alice: Or I could go back and work for a couple of days to see how it feels
Alice:不回家也行
Alice: Or I could just not go home
刘婷:慧云慧云是不是还在呢
Liu Ting: Is Huiyun still here?
Alice:对啊他要等到那个他那个签证嘛
Alice: Yeah, he's waiting for his visa, right?
Alice:他一签就签
Alice: As soon as he gets it
Alice:可能他要坚持到6月7月
Alice: He might have to hold on until June or July
刘婷:哦你这蛮像哦
Liu Ting: Oh, you're quite similar
刘婷:好好免签啊
Liu Ting: Good, visa-free
刘婷:哦旅游免签啊
Liu Ting: Oh, visa-free travel
Alice:他要是那啥他
Alice: If he does that, he
Alice:他相当于打黑工了
Alice: He's basically working illegally
刘婷:呃确确确实
Liu Ting: Uh, indeed
Alice:别搞别搞
Alice: Don't mess around
女嘉宾:行了我走了
Female Guest: Alright, I'm leaving
Alice:好
Alice: Okay
Alice:嗯上去吧
Alice: Yeah, go on up
Alice:你到学校要告诉我哦
Alice: Let me know when you get to school, okay?
Alice:嗯拜拜
Alice: Hmm, bye-bye
女嘉宾:拜拜拜拜
Female Guest: Bye-bye, bye-bye
Alice:拜拜
Alice: Bye-bye
刘婷:我以为这是两个公交呢
Liu Ting: I thought these were two buses
刘婷:结果这么下来的
Liu Ting: Turns out they came like this
刘婷:我天啊
Liu Ting: Oh my god
Alice:我靠真牛逼
Alice: Wow, amazing
刘婷:比我命还长
Liu Ting: Longer than my life
Alice:休得胡说
Alice: Stop talking nonsense
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Alice:婷儿今天晚上我得搂着你睡
Alice: Ting, I need to cuddle with you tonight.
刘婷:你别
Liu Ting: No, you don't.
Alice:咋 被我搂
Alice: Why not? Being cuddled by me...
Alice:是你的荣幸
Alice: is an honor for you.
刘婷:我怕怕
刘婷:哎你们大概什么时候走啊
Liu Ting: Hey, when are you guys leaving?
Alice:什么大概什么时候走
Alice: When are we leaving?
Alice:明天吧其实后天上午结束走
Alice: Tomorrow, actually the day after tomorrow morning.
Alice:但是我周二不得回去吗
Alice: But I have to go back on Tuesday.
Alice:我明天晚上走吧
Alice: So I'll leave tomorrow night.
Alice:明天晚上吧
Alice: Tomorrow night.
Alice:明天下午和晚上我回去了哎
Alice: I'll head back tomorrow afternoon and evening.
刘婷:大概是我是下午 2点有一个面试
Liu Ting: I have an interview around 2 PM.
Alice:嗯你
Alice: Oh, you...
刘婷:我大概睁眼的时候
Liu Ting: I usually wake up around...
刘婷:呃 9 9点
Liu Ting: uh, 9, 9 AM.
刘婷:10点 11点
Liu Ting: 10, 11 AM.
Alice:你睁眼可真不早啊
Alice: You sure wake up late.
Alice:我我不不不是很想吃其实
Alice: I don't really feel like eating, actually.
Alice:因为我一般早上就两个蛋
Alice: I usually just have two eggs in the morning.
Alice:但是我不是要压缩那个吃饭时间
Alice: But I need to compress my eating time...
Alice:就是到固定的每天几个小时吗
Alice: to a few fixed hours each day.
刘婷:嗯
Liu Ting: Hmm.
Alice:啊所以我基本上就是
Alice: So I'm basically...
Alice:现在属于早上就是空腹状态
Alice: in a fasting state every morning now.
Alice:但是我可以给你点个外卖虽然不报销
Alice: But I can order you some takeout, although I won't reimburse it.
Alice:或者咱俩出来吃吗
Alice: Or we can go out to eat.
Alice:你就随便挑
Alice: You pick.
Alice:我给你买
Alice: I'll buy.
刘婷:啊呀姐耶
Liu Ting: Ah, sis, yay.
Alice:耶
Alice: Yay.
刘婷:我才觉得你像姐
Liu Ting: Now you really feel like a sister.
Alice:我操 我真服了
Alice: Damn, I'm impressed.
Alice:他给你报金币了才是姐
Alice: When he pays you in gold coins, then he's a sister.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
刘婷:8号线坐到朱金庄再扫他们一下
Liu Ting: Take line 8 to Zhujin Station and scan them.
刘婷:就直接到家门口了
Liu Ting: Then you'll be right at the doorstep.
Alice:这灯亮着了吧
Alice: Is the light on?
刘婷:亮着呢
Liu Ting: It's on.
Alice:行
Alice: Alright.
Alice:你是不是挺容易就跟别人搞好关系的
Alice: Are you the type who easily gets along with others?
Alice:就是你挺容易交朋友的
Alice: Like, you make friends easily?
刘婷:嗯还行吧
Liu Ting: Yeah, I guess.
刘婷:但我感觉我遇到的人就是有点奇葩
Liu Ting: But I feel like I meet some really odd people.
刘婷:有的一些嗯
Liu Ting: Some of them, yeah.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
刘婷:比如  那种
刘婷:之前我也把他就是当成什么好朋友
Liu Ting: I used to consider one of them a good friend.
刘婷:就不能说称好朋友吧
Liu Ting: Well, not really a good friend.
刘婷:就是至少成好室友
Liu Ting: But at least a good roommate.
刘婷:结果他就是哎呦咦很膈应
Liu Ting: But she turned out to be really weird.
Alice:噫
Alice: Ew.
刘婷:一般吗一般就是会有一个呃
Liu Ting: Usually, there's a phase where you, uh...
刘婷:审审视这么一个阶段
Liu Ting: You kind of scrutinize them.
刘婷:如果觉得这个人还
Liu Ting: If you think they're...
Alice:卧槽 没联网
Alice: Damn, no internet.
刘婷:别吧哥们
Liu Ting: Come on, man.
Alice:哈哈哈我才害怕呢
Alice: Haha, I was so scared.
Alice:我才害怕呢 数据丢了都
Alice: I was so scared the data was lost.
Alice:故意丢了没
Alice: Did you lose it on purpose?
Alice:你别给他关了吧
Alice: Don't turn it off, please.
刘婷:不是我放兜里好像误触了兄弟
Liu Ting: No, I think I accidentally touched it in my pocket, bro.
Alice:你这是让我心肌梗死啊姐妹
Alice: You're giving me a heart attack, girl.
Alice:哈哈就是你那个
Alice: Haha, like seriously...
刘婷:现在有
Liu Ting: Now it's back.
Alice:我看看有没有
Alice: Let me see if it's there.
刘婷:呃我记得我印象里好像是
Liu Ting: Uh, I remember when we left, I checked my phone and it was still there.
刘婷:是咱们出发那阵我看手机我这还有呢
Liu Ting: Maybe it got lost when we reached the bus stop, yeah.
刘婷:可能走到公交站那边就没了嗯
Liu Ting: It might have disappeared there.
Alice:嗯:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:啊卧槽
Alice: Ah, damn it.
Alice:怎么还登录啊
Alice: Why is it still logging in?
Alice:完了
Alice: It's over.
刘婷:你微信
Liu Ting: Your WeChat?
刘婷:要不问他们一下这个东西怎么登
Liu Ting: Why don't you ask them how to log in?
Alice:唉 算了 走吧
Alice: Sigh, forget it, let's go.
Alice:没拍但是他怎么还亮着呢
Alice: I didn't record, but why is it still on?
Alice:就不知道了 啊
Alice: No idea, ugh.
刘婷:有变是吧
Liu Ting: Did something change?
Alice:假装不知道 得了
Alice: Just pretend you don't know.
Alice:无所谓
Alice: Whatever.
Alice:小事
Alice: No big deal.
刘婷:我觉得
Liu Ting: I think...
刘婷:哎呦今天那个短发的姑娘哇
Liu Ting: Hey, that girl with the short hair today, wow.
Alice:嗯好酷
Alice: Yeah, so cool.
刘婷:好辣呀
Liu Ting: So hot.
刘婷:哈哈spicy哈哈哈
Liu Ting: Haha, spicy, haha.
刘婷:那个也是
Liu Ting: And that one too.
刘婷:就是他们叫的朋友吗
Liu Ting: Are they the friends they mentioned?
刘婷:那是剧组的
Liu Ting: They're from the crew.
Alice:那是剧组的
Alice: They're from the crew.
刘婷:噢
Liu Ting: Oh.
刘婷:我寻思你们都不在一个学校里
Liu Ting: I was wondering, you guys aren't even in the same school.
刘婷:你这个项目是怎么凑成的呀
Liu Ting: How did you put this project together?
Alice:求求我我告诉你
Alice: Beg me, and I'll tell you.
刘婷:你有啥癖好
Liu Ting: What are your hobbies?
Alice:我确实
Alice: Well, I...
刘婷:告诉我吧
Liu Ting: Tell me.
刘婷:肯德基爷爷
Liu Ting: Colonel Sanders.
Alice:问问肯得基爷爷
Alice: Ask Colonel Sanders.
刘婷:小美姐姐
Liu Ting: Sister Xiaomei.
Alice:小美姐姐
Alice: Sister Xiaomei.
Alice:不告诉你
Alice: Not telling you.
刘婷:小美
Liu Ting: Xiaomei.
Alice:小美小美
Alice: Xiaomei, Xiaomei.
Alice:哎
Alice: Hey.
刘婷:好有才艺呀
Liu Ting: So talented.
Alice:别
Alice: Stop.
Alice:求求你
Alice: Please.
Alice:啊哟
Alice: Oh my.
Alice:你快滚
Alice: Just go away.
Alice:啊对刚才是彩排
Alice: Oh right, that was a rehearsal.
Alice:我记得有那个什么悠哉什么啥的
Alice: I remember there was something like "leisure" or something.
刘婷:发货
Liu Ting: Ship it.
Alice:找找
Alice: Look for it.
Alice:叫啥来着他 他叫
Alice: What was his name again, he was called...
Alice:谢
Alice: Xie...
Alice:彬竹
Alice: Binzhu.
Alice:你拍一下
Alice: Take a picture.
Alice:算了我直接去复制吧
Alice: Forget it, I'll just go copy it.
刘婷:ok
Liu Ting: Okay.
刘婷:哦这样就能连上了啊
Liu Ting: Oh, so this is how you connect it.
Alice:啊这怎么变成L3了
Alice: Ah, why did it become L3?
Alice:没有
Alice: No.
Alice:噢 录着呢
Alice: Oh, it's recording.
Alice:还剩30多
Alice: There's still over 30 left.
Alice:差不多就三个小时 半个小时吧
Alice: Almost three hours, half an hour.
刘婷:差不多
Liu Ting: About right.
Alice:还好 没丢
Alice: Good, nothing was lost.
Alice:我们几点出来的 差不多 没差不多都在录着
Alice: What time did we come out? About right, it's been recording.
刘婷:7点半之后肯定是
Liu Ting: After 7:30 for sure.
Alice:我什么时候事上眼镜的呀
Alice: When did I start wearing glasses?
Alice:吃饭以后
Alice: After dinner.
刘婷:跳舞之前
Liu Ting: Before dancing.
Alice:跳舞之前
Alice: Before dancing.
Alice:这才半个小时吗
Alice: Has it only been half an hour?
Alice:它是不是丢了一段
Alice: Did it lose a segment?
Alice:感觉不止半个小时
Alice: It feels like more than half an hour.
Alice:中间那一段应该是没有
Alice: That middle part is probably missing.
Alice:算了 就这样吧
Alice: Forget it, just leave it.
Alice:能录多少录多少吧
Alice: Record as much as we can.
Alice:你认路吗
Alice: Do you know the way?
刘婷:认路啊
Liu Ting: I know the way.
Alice:ok 那就好
Alice: Okay, that's good.
Alice:你春章怎么样啊
Alice: How's your spring chapter going?
刘婷:我说no这他是按学院招的
Liu Ting: I said no, it was based on the academy's recruitment.
刘婷:我没进学院
Liu Ting: I didn't get into the academy.
刘婷:都是什么金融岗位不是我喜欢的
Liu Ting: All the positions are in finance, not what I like.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Alice:没事
Alice: It's okay.
Alice:没得关系
Alice: No problem.
Alice:改天教我视频剪辑呗 难不难啊
Alice: Teach me video editing someday, is it hard?
Alice:还可以啊
Alice: It's doable.
Alice:不是很难
Alice: Not too hard.
Alice:需要什么技巧啥的吗
Alice: Does it need any special skills?
Alice:有什么技巧啥的吗
Alice: Are there any tricks to it?
刘婷:嗯我想想哈
Liu Ting: Hmm, let me think.
刘婷:技巧就是剪辑
Liu Ting: The trick is just editing.
刘婷:剪辑不就是
Liu Ting: Editing is just...
刘婷:就是很
Liu Ting: It's very...
Alice:你笨蛋
Alice: You dummy.
刘婷:就是一个很笨蛋式的软件
Liu Ting: It's just a very dumb software.
刘婷:我看技巧操作不难
Liu Ting: I think the technique isn't hard.
刘婷:主要是
Liu Ting: The main thing is...
Alice:脚本
Alice: The script.
刘婷:脚本要写脚本
Liu Ting: You have to write the script.
刘婷:如果是没有编导的话就自己写脚本
Liu Ting: If there's no director, you'll have to write it yourself.
Alice:OK
Alice: OK.
刘婷:而且就是
Liu Ting: Plus...
刘婷:如果公司有那种剪映VIP的话
Liu Ting: If the company has that VIP editing software...
刘婷:一定要拿过来用
Liu Ting: You definitely have to use it.
刘婷:真的很好用
Liu Ting: It's really good.
Alice:行
Alice: Alright.
Alice:我用过剪映
Alice: I've used it before.
Alice:剪过片子
Alice: Edited some videos.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Alice:OGCM麦当劳
Alice: OGCM McDonald's.
Alice:哈哈感觉这几天又胖回来了
Alice: Haha, I feel like I've gained weight again these days.
刘婷:没事反正吃的也不是自己的钱
Liu Ting: No worries, it's not your money anyway.
Alice:主要是胖了呀
Alice: The main thing is I've gained weight!
刘婷:身材和口腹之欲至少有一个是满足的
Liu Ting: As long as either your figure or appetite is satisfied.
Alice:我靠
Alice: Oh my God.
刘婷:你现在是两个都满足
Liu Ting: You now have both satisfied.
刘婷:哎不对
Liu Ting: Wait, no.
刘婷:身材没有满足
Liu Ting: Your figure isn't satisfied.
刘婷:但是钱包和口腹之欲更能满足
Liu Ting: But your wallet and appetite are more satisfied.
Alice:拐吗
Alice: Shall we go?
刘婷:走走走走
Liu Ting: Let's go, let's go.
Alice:这啥呀这么多灯
Alice: What is this, so many lights?
Alice:小狗
Alice: Puppy.
刘婷:怎么顶格了
Liu Ting: How did it reach the limit?
刘婷:灯确实有点奇怪啊
Liu Ting: The lights are indeed a bit weird.
Alice:确实
Alice:别搞哈哈
Alice: Stop messing around, haha.
Alice:别搞
Alice: Stop it.
Alice:你要我命啊
Alice: Are you trying to kill me?
Alice:我要杀了你
Alice: I'm going to kill you.
Alice:快点快
Alice: Hurry up, quick.
Alice:脚趾杆你
Alice: Toes, you
Alice:你干什么啊你干什么啊
Alice: What are you doing, what are you doing
Alice:你干什么
Alice: What are you doing
Alice:哎 录着 还好 40分钟
Alice: Oh, it's recording, good, 40 minutes
Alice:这不对啊
Alice: This isn't right
Alice:这不对啊 怎么一共就40分钟呢
Alice: This isn't right, how is it only 40 minutes in total
Alice:算了 就这样吧
Alice: Forget it, it is what it is
Alice:刘一凡
Alice: Liu Yifan
Alice:L
Alice: L
Alice:你是XL
Alice: You're an XL
Alice:哦 还好
Alice: Oh, that's good
Alice:29 现在二十 还有二十三分钟
Alice: 29, now it's twenty, there's still twenty-three minutes left
Alice:无妨
Alice: No worries
Alice:接着咋走啊
Alice: Where do we go next?
刘婷:直走
Liu Ting: Straight ahead
Alice:哦 哦我认路了
Alice: Oh, oh I recognize the way
Alice:看见了
Alice: I see it
Alice:给你一个表现的机会
Alice: Giving you a chance to shine
Alice:对
Alice:怎么啦
Alice: What's up
Jake:哈哈哈沙雕
Jake: Hahaha, silly
Alice:易如反掌易如反掌
Alice: Piece of cake, piece of cake
Alice:好好好
Alice: Alright, alright
Alice:哎哟 五一快来吧
Alice: Oh gosh, May 1st, hurry up
Alice:只想放假
Alice: Just want a holiday
Alice:放假放假 手机给你那了吧
Alice: Holiday, holiday, where's my phone?
刘婷:什么
Liu Ting: What?
Alice:手机手机 我手机
Alice: Phone, phone, my phone
刘婷:你手里
Liu Ting: In your hand
Alice:哦哦哦 我草我草
Alice: Oh, oh, oh my gosh, my gosh
Alice:对不起
Alice: Sorry
刘婷:完蛋了
Liu Ting: It's over
Alice:我真
Alice: I really
刘婷:完蛋了
Liu Ting: It's over
Alice:对不起我有病
Alice: Sorry, I'm a mess
Alice:还是在脑子上
Alice: Especially in my head
Alice:唉 这个门关着呢
Alice: Ugh, this door is closed
Alice:小猫 回家了
Alice: Little cat, let's go home
Alice:别玩抽像
Alice: Don't play abstract
Alice:我还以为有小狗小猫的脚步跟着我们
Alice: I thought there were little dog or cat footsteps following us
Alice:他敢
Alice: He dares
Alice:他敢谁来谁死
Alice: If he dares, whoever comes will die
Alice:我跟你说
Alice: I'm telling you
Alice:怎么了我不能保护你吗
Alice: What's up? Can't I protect you?
Alice:咦
Alice: Eh?
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on
Alice:没人呢
Alice: No one's here
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Alice:人呢
Alice: Where are the people?
Alice:哦上楼了
Alice: Oh, went upstairs
Alice:不知道
Alice: No idea
Alice:这咋没人收拾
Alice: Why is no one cleaning up?
Alice:唉我怎么感觉不是我们楼上的声音
Alice: Sigh, why does it sound like it's not from upstairs?
Alice:没人收拾呀
Alice: No one's cleaning up
Alice:可能是
Alice: Maybe
Alice:哈哈哈再来点嘛
Alice: Hahaha, more please
刘婷:我吃饱了
Liu Ting: I'm full
Alice:楼上有人吗
Alice: Is anyone upstairs?
Alice:啊真的都不在了
Alice: Ah, really no one is here
Alice:哦有人有人哦
Alice: Oh, there's someone, there's someone
Alice:关门
Alice: Close the door
Alice:有虫
Alice: There's a bug
Alice:可以关了 有wifi了
Alice: You can close it now, there's Wi-Fi
Alice:麦当劳汉堡
Alice: McDonald's burger
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah
Shure: 今夜我们在此欢聚
Shure: Tonight we gather here
Alice:我靠
Alice: Damn
男嘉宾:哎哟喂
Male Guest: Oh my
Katrina: 说不清
Katrina: Can't explain it
Shure: 今夜我们在此快乐
Shure: Tonight we are happy here
Nicous: 再再来一点
Nicous: More, more
男嘉宾:已经开饮一天了
Male Guest: We've been drinking all day
Alice:这什么环节啊
Alice: What's this segment?
Katrina: 忘记今宵
Katrina: Forget tonight
Shure的女友:难忘今宵
Shure's GF: Unforgettable tonight
Jake:赶上clothing了
Jake: Just in time for clothing
Shure: 我们相聚一堂
Shure: We gather together
Shure: 在这ego house
Shure: Here at ego house
Jack: 什么呀
Jack: What?
Alice:有点抽象
Alice: It's a bit abstract
Jake:我跟你哈哈哈哈
Jake: I'm with you, hahaha.
刘婷:ego house
Liu Ting: Ego house.
Jack: 顺间就服气了
Jack: Instantly impressed.
女嘉宾:你们坐吧
Female Guest: You guys sit down.
Alice:哦对我的衣服没晾哦
Alice: Oh right, I forgot to hang my clothes.
Shure: 我们难忘今宵
Shure: We'll never forget tonight.
Alice:晾个衣服
Alice: Hang some clothes.
Shure: 我们难忘未来
Shure: We won't forget the future.
Jack: 难忘未来什么
Jack: Forget the future? What?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈你忘什么东西
Jake: Hahaha, what are you forgetting?
男嘉宾:我笑死了
Male Guest: I'm dying of laughter.
Alice:我笑死了
Alice: I'm dying of laughter.
Katrina: 还没过呢就难忘
Katrina: It's not even over yet and you're already saying "unforgettable."
Alice:难忘未来可还行
Alice: "Unforgettable future" sounds good.
Alice:哈哈
Alice:哎呀这洗衣机怎么这么埋你看你看这上面好多沫
Alice: Oh man, why is this washing machine so dirty, look at all this foam.
Alice:我抽
Alice: I'm speechless.
Alice:朋友再见
Alice: Goodbye, my friend.
Alice:刘婷你上去唱一曲
Alice: Liu Ting, go sing a song.
Shure: 去迎接明天的快乐吧
Shure: Let's embrace the happiness of tomorrow.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Alice:我的天
Alice: Oh my god.
Shure: 多好啊
Shure: How nice.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 这个我们就叫做离谱对吧
Shure: This, we call it ridiculous, right?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Mm-hmm.
Alice:那也得晾着
Alice: But it needs to be hung.
Alice:没地方晾就这一点
Alice: There's no place to hang it, just this bit.
Alice:没事你明天走的时候早上把他收回去
Alice:有雨你会接我吗
Alice: Will you pick me up if it rains?
Alice:走走走
Alice: Let's go, let's go.
Shure: Ego life全体成员
Shure: Ego life members.
Alice:上面看节目去
Alice: Let's go watch the show upstairs.
Jake:啥 哈哈
Jake: What? Haha.
Katrina: 立的都爬了
Katrina: Everything's collapsed.
Alice:走走走走
Alice: Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Alice:你渴了拿水喝啊
Alice: If you're thirsty, drink some water.
Alice:我就不跟你说了
Alice: I'm not talking to you anymore.
Alice:就不招待你了
Alice: I'm not entertaining you anymore.
Alice:我的亲妈呀
Alice: Oh my dear mom.
男嘉宾:所以所以你们这一个礼拜
Male Guest: So, so you guys, this whole week...
女嘉宾:退票
Female Guest: Refund the tickets.
男嘉宾:都是天天这么精神病吗
Male Guest: Are you guys crazy like this every day?
Shure: 新来的朋友啊
Shure: Ah, a new friend.
Shure: 我们每天都很快乐
Shure: We're happy every day.
Shure: 来吧快来到美好的ego life吧
Shure: Come on, join the wonderful ego life.
Jack: 美好啊是没有好那个好吧
Jack: Wonderful? There's nothing good about it.
Shure: ego life是一个
Shure: Ego life is...
Shure: 快乐的大家庭
Shure: A happy big family.
Shure: 是一个没有纷争的大家庭
Shure: A big family without disputes.
Shure: 是一个完蛋
Shure: It's a disaster.
Shure: 我被美女包围了的大家庭
Shure: A big family where I'm surrounded by beauties.
Shure: Ego life
Shure: Ego life.
Jack: 就这句话比较现实
Jack: That's the most realistic thing you've said.
Shure: 带给了我快乐
Shure: It brings me happiness.
Katrina: 这是诗歌朗诵
Katrina: Is this a poetry reading?
Shure: 带给了我金币
Shure: It brings me gold coins.
Jake:Ego Coin
Jake: Ego Coin.